bem eu sou uma psicóloga muitas muitas
vezes que me conhecem nem confundir
porque eu sou psicólogo social e eu
costumo dizer que a minha escolha pela
psicologia social não fazer uma escolha
foi esse é um campo da psicologia no
especial para mim mas que pra mim foi
quase um imperativo eu chamo de
imperativo genético uma brincadeira mas
eu vou explicar para vocês porque eu
nasci numa pequena cidade de minas
gerais interior de minas assim como
itabira
filha de uma dona de casa muito simples
muito muito dedicada
mas também muito elegans e de um
caminhoneiro que eu apresento aqui pra
vocês é muito trabalhador muito alegre e
muito cheio de histórias do pai adorava
andar a contar uma história
o meu pai foi pra mim a minha primeira
conexão com o mundo
claro que às vezes vocês não podem
imaginar seus hoje um mundo sem internet
sem telefone sem computadores né
o mundo da criança na década de 70 e 80
assim no mundo com letras maiúsculas
como o que as crianças hoje era
tecnológica consegue se conectar
mas pra mim é as idas e vindas do meu
pai em uma viagem outro eram sempre
carregado de expectativas de novos
conhecimentos
toda vez que ouvia o motor do seu velho
caminhão chegando eu saio correndo o
coração disparava eu ia correndo não
contra a coreia
claro a gente a saudade contava muito
mas eu tinha sempre a expectativa de que
ele traria algo que de alguma forma de
conectar ia com lugares que eu não
conhecia e é assim mesmo
toda vez ele trazia ele chegava trazer
uma fruta doce uma comida exótica
às vezes apenas histórias e piadas novas
que ele aprendia na viagem de vez em
quando também quando sobrava uma
graninha ele acaba levantar a gente
trabalhou lá o meu pai e me fazia
imaginar as coisas com tanta diversidade
que a minha vontade de conhecer os
lugares e os personagens das histórias é
imensa
pra mim saber que o mundo era muito
maior do que aquela pequena e
provinciana cidade mineira era muito
reconfortante saber que eu não precisava
me conformar com nada daquilo que eu vi
ali à minha volta embora tivesse uma
infância muito feliz era o massa
e foi assim que eu e meus irmãos
aprendemos a gostar da estrada e que
como todo trabalhador da estrada é
agente carinhosamente chama de trecho e
vocês não podem imaginar a gente
gostando de uma estrada bastante um
trecho desse jeito o consultório a
rotina do consultório uma adi pede
e foi assim que a minha profissão me
colocou na estrada e um dia me trouxe
itapira após enfrentar um engarrafamento
na br 381 na noite fria de 2012
quando cheguei não encontrei isso o
evento ao ar livre lotado de gente
imaginem vocês
as pessoas estavam ali naquela área de
eventos para assistir um filme que
celebravam os 70 anos
posso garantir a vocês não era nenhuma
rodovia dessas pessoas aguardava que o
documentário com tanta ansiedade com
tanta expectativa
e pra completar enquanto esperavam a
exibição do filme é pipoqueiro serviu
pipocas pouca justiça carácter como
aqueles que ficavam na porta do cinema
na década de 40
eu muito cansado da viagem sentindo
muito frio e sentir como se eu tivesse
entrado numa realidade paralela
primeiro porque eu esperava encontrar
neste evento no máximo empregados e ex
empregados da empresa e para minha
surpresa
tinha gente de todo canto da cidade nas
margens dessas ocupações representando
várias gerações
quando o filme começou a festa
excelência tão absoluto até comecei a
pensar que o barulho dos meus nossos e
música que prêmio the third strike como
agora não estão tremendo nervoso at vero
incomodando a platéia e quando terminou
terminou a exibição do filme que eu
olhei à minha volta eu vi homens e
mulheres de olhos vermelhos e muitas
lágrimas
muitos sorrisos e aplausos muitos
aplausos das pessoas não paravam de
cloud gente mas de onde vem tanta emoção
de onde vem tanto afeto o que será que
conecta a história dessas pessoas a essa
história eu vim aqui pela primeira vez
começando a trabalhar na mineração e com
estereótipos na cabeça
a relação da dívida com a mineração é de
amor e ódio e muitas vezes muito mais
ódio e amor
naquele momento eu estava vendo emoção
ao afeto
fiquei com essa coisa na cabeça
eis a relação dessas pessoas relação
dessa cidade com a mineração não é
apenas uma questão econômica
ela vai além
comecei a procurar foi entender a
história né e descobrir que ela é
narrada com a seguinte só em 1944 é os
primeiros blocos uma pedra brilhante
começaram a ser retirados e conectaram
definitivamente a história de tavira o
mundo conector definitivamente essas
pessoas com o mundo
o trabalho dessas pessoas que estão aí
nessa foto e muitas outras conectaram
essa cidade com o mundo
isso é encontrar o velho sentimento
aquele que eu tinha em relação ao meu
pai
alguém que por meio do trabalho conecta
uma pequena cidade de minas ao mundo e
então começa a entender também que essa
relação de amor e ódio
talvez estivesse muito mais a ver com
uma necessidade de se discutir a
autonomia versus dependência à cidade de
itabira conectar com o mundo ela chegou
mar atravessa os oceanos e ganha mares
ganha outros países
a empresa que a filha da cidade onde ela
cresceu hoje está em mais de 30 países e
em cada país de cada lugar de se ter um
pouquinho de itabira que exporta
talentos exporta conhecimento exporta
tecnologia história experiência exporta
orgulho das origens
eu costumo dizer que hoje também exporta
pedras e olhos que brilham está em todos
os lugares
está a questão da da discussão sobre a
dependência de uma relação de uma de uma
atividade econômica
ela assim como a dependência de um filho
da minha opinião ela vai muito além é
inadiável mas ela vai muito além de uma
questão econômica
ela também é uma questão identitária e
como nós estamos falando de uma cidade
de seus grupos
seus trabalhadores
a gente está falando a identidade
coletiva a identidade coletiva ela é um
conceito da psicologia social é um
construto história é assim dá ao longo
da história de um lugar e através dela
as os indivíduos e grupos compartilham
histórias compartilham valores que
compartilham normas e vão se
constituindo ao longo do tempo
e eis aí minha gente é uma questão muito
importante em relação às relações de
trabalho como que as relações de
trabalho
forçam a identidade de um lugar a
identidade da cidade do seu povo
sobretudo as relações de trabalho uma
atividade tão forte quando é tão
marcantes como é o caso da mineração é é
muito é muito interessante pensar que
essa imagem nessa imagem das pedras dos
blocos do minério com que eles estão
como ela está forte na identidade de
itabira é muito muito importante foi
muito importante pra mim essa
experiência ao ver tanta emoção ao ver
tanto envolvimento com com aquele filme
com aquela aquela história que estava
sendo
o estado eu fui eu me pensando o quanto
era sério quanto é importante o trabalho
que eu ia fazer aqui não é possível mais
pensar em sustentabilidade sem pensar
diversificação econômica e essa
discussão ela não é uma discussão fácil
ela não está pronta ela depende de todos
nós
eu descobri que o que me trazer aqui
naquela noite fria de inverno não era
mesmo só mais uma
uma simples experiência profissional
era também uma experiência pessoal muito
importante é muito emblemático para quem
trabalha na mineração conhecer itapira é
imprescindível itabira
apesar dessa identidade apesar de
oferecer
apesar de ser forte culturalmente apesar
de está no mundo através da sua arte
através de seu povo através da mineração
mas não somente também da mineração
ela hoje ainda convive com 20 como a
mineração urbano íntima uma convivência
muito íntima quase utilidade agência
exige diálogo cuidado respeito luto e
essa relação é muito importante para
todos nós que ela seja cada vez mais
refém respeitosa que ela abra cada vez
mais possibilidades e caminhos para o
futuro todas as discussões aqui nos
fazem pensar nesse futuro e conhecem a
vida pra mim foi além de muito
emblemático do ponto de vista
profissional
do ponto de vista pessoal e fez nem
falei que estava aquele antigo
sentimento que eu tinha em relação ao
meu pai saber que o trabalho afeto e
emoção ao juntos e hoje viaja
conheço muitos lugares pelo mundo e
arrisco a dizer que conhece de fato
lugar é conhecer seu povo é conhecer seu
ofício é saber da sua luta pela
sobrevivência e conhece as redes de
solidariedade que compõem sua identidade
e que conhece a onda sem dúvida uma
forma de nos conhecer também de reforçar
a importância e orgulho das nossas
origens e saber que a autoridade ea
diversidade é que compõem reforça nossa
identidade
obrigado